From WBZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And let me just, I'm just going to reach out and retune your signal here a little bit from whatever Public Radio station or podcast streaming service you're listening to. And where we're going to is 101.5 Truckee Tahoe Radio in northern California near Lake Tahoe. And I'm going to retune from today to April of last year.
来自芝加哥WBZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请容许我稍微调整一下你们正在收听的公共广播电台或播客流媒体服务的频率。我们现在要去的是北加州太浩湖附近的 Truckee Tahoe 广播电台 101.5。我将要把时间从今天调整回去年四月。
It's springtime and the opening weekend of fishing season, and that means it's time for the return of the 101.5 Fishing Report, brought to you every week by Mountain Hardware and Sports in Truckee.
现在是春季，也是钓鱼季的开幕周末，这意味着 101.5 钓鱼报告又要回归了，该报告每周由特拉基的 Mountain Hardware and Sports 为您播出。
101.5 is the one radio station in Truckee, and the Fishing Report runs Friday, Saturday, Sunday every week, three times a day, during the summer, which is about right for a mountain town filled with lots of people who are there because they love the outdoors.
101.5 是特拉基唯一的广播电台，钓鱼报告在夏季每周五、周六、周日播出三次，对于一个充满户外爱好者的山城来说，这再合适不过了。
Now let's talk fishing. The Truckee River has great flows for springtime right now. It's not too high and minimal snow melt is happening. Please be sure to wade carefully near the shorelines. That's where the fish are hanging out, so be sure not to scare them.
现在来谈谈钓鱼。特拉基河目前的春季流量很棒。水位不是太高，融雪也比较少。请务必小心在岸边涉水。那是鱼儿聚集的地方，所以一定要注意不要惊吓到它们。
Each fishing report has lots of helpful information about how much water is flowing through the Truckee and Little Truckee Rivers at various spots, which affects fishing. And then there are long sections that, I have to admit, even though I grew up fishing on the Chesapeake Bay, are complete gibberish to me.
每一份钓鱼报告都包含大量有用的信息，关于特拉基河和小特拉基河各个地点的流量，这些都会影响钓鱼情况。不过还有一些很长的部分，我不得不承认，尽管我是在切萨皮克湾长大并钓鱼的，但对我来说完全像天书一样。
Indicator and euro nymphing are producing the best results for anglers. Dry fly favorites include EC Caddis, Parachute Adams, and Cripple March Browns.
指示器和欧式若虫拟饵钓法为垂钓者带来了最好的成果。干式拟饵的最爱包括 EC Caddis、Parachute Adams 和 Cripple March Browns。
Fly fishing. A listener to 101.5, Emily McAllister, sent us this Fishing Report and a bunch of others, because this past summer, as she listened, she noticed that the 101.5 Fishing Report-- this steady, sturdy, unflappable piece of angling boosterism-- seemed to be telling the kind of story that hadn't ever shown up there before in the Fishing Report. The oddness began in July.
飞钓。101.5 的一位听众艾米丽·麦卡利斯特给我们发来了这份钓鱼报告以及其他很多份，因为去年夏天她在收听时注意到，101.5 的钓鱼报告——这段平稳、坚定、从容不迫的钓鱼宣传——似乎正在讲述一种以前从未在钓鱼报告中出现过的故事。这种怪异感始于七月。
Well, right out of the chute this week, anglers are advised to stop fishing the Truckee River from noon until about 6:00 PM due to warm water temperatures. Catch and release is very difficult on the fish right now in the afternoon. So please, fish only early mornings and the last light of day.
本周一开场，建议垂钓者由于水温偏高，在中午到下午6点之间停止在特拉基河钓鱼。下午时段进行“钓后即放”对鱼类来说非常困难。所以，请务必只在清晨和日落前钓鱼。
So that was the start. But it was really two weeks later, August 6, that Emily's ears perked up when The Fishing Report told people to carry a piece of gear lots of us don't usually associate with fishing.
这就是开始。但真正让艾米丽竖起耳朵的是两周后，也就是8月6日，当时的钓鱼报告告诉人们要携带一件我们很多人通常不会与钓鱼联系在一起的装备。
Anglers are still being advised not to fish the river during peak temperatures. Please be sure to bring a thermometer to test the temperatures before casting. Anything above 66 degrees makes it very strenuous on the fish.
建议垂钓者在最高气温期间不要在河里钓鱼。下钩前请务必携带温度计测试水温。任何高于66度（华氏度）的水温对鱼类来说都非常吃力。
Bring a thermometer. It was the warmest summer on record in California, not much rain or snow that year. Hence, the warm water. Then at the end of August, something else made its way into The Fishing Report.
带上温度计。那是加州有记录以来最热的夏天，那一年雨雪很少。因此，水温很高。然后到了八月底，又有别的东西进入了钓鱼报告。
To provide better public and firefighter safety, due to extreme fire conditions throughout northern California and strained firefighting resources throughout the country, the Forest Service has implemented a temporary closure of nine national forests in California. Anglers are currently prohibited from fishing Boca, Prosser, Stampede, and Jackson Meadows reservoirs, Lakes Basin, Little Truckee River, and any section of the Truckee River that's on National Forest land until September 7.
为了提供更好的公众和消防员安全，由于整个北加州处于极端火灾条件，且全国范围内的消防资源紧张，林务局已临时关闭了加州的九个国家森林。目前禁止垂钓者在博卡、普罗瑟、斯坦皮德和杰克逊梅多斯水库、湖泊流域、小特拉基河以及位于国家森林土地上的特拉基河任何河段进行垂钓，直至9月7日。
He does point out two places where you still can fish, though he says water levels there are very low.
他指出了两个仍然可以钓鱼的地方，尽管他说那里的水位很低。
And that's it for this week's Fishing Report. Until next time, tight lines and hope for rain.
本周的钓鱼报告就到这里。下次见，祝你鱼线紧绷，祈祷下雨。
They don't get rain. Things don't improve. There's the Dixie fire to the north of Lake Tahoe and the Caldor fire to the south. A day after this report runs, a mandatory evacuation is ordered for a big area south of Lake Tahoe. Lots of other people flee, as well. And Truckee's like a ghost town. But a week later, the September 3 Fishing Report still goes on the air, cheerful as ever.
他们没有迎来降雨。情况也没有好转。太浩湖北部发生了迪克西大火，南部发生了卡尔多大火。这份报告播出一天后，太浩湖南部的大片区域收到了强制撤离令。许多其他人也逃离了这里。特拉基就像一座鬼城。但一周后，9月3日的钓鱼报告依然照常播出，一如既往地欢快。
It's time to stop wishing and get fishing. This is the weekly 101.5 Fishing Report, brought to you by Mountain Hardware and Sports in Truckee. The Forest Service has temporarily closed all national forests in the state. These forest closures include local rivers and reservoirs and affect where anglers can fish. Please respect these current closures. The tentative date for forests to reopen is September 13.
是时候停止空想，开始钓鱼了。这是每周一次的 101.5 钓鱼报告，由特拉基的 Mountain Hardware and Sports 为您播出。林务局已暂时关闭了该州所有的国家森林。这些森林关闭区包括当地河流和水库，影响了垂钓者的钓鱼地点。请尊重当前的关闭规定。森林重新开放的暂定日期为9月13日。
OK, let's jump ahead a month to October 15. Evacuation orders have been lifted. The Caldor and Dixie fires will soon be out. But there's a new problem.
好的，让我们跳过一个月，来到10月15日。撤离令已经解除。卡尔多大火和迪克西大火即将熄灭。但又出现了一个新问题。
The flows on the Truckee River are minimal these days, with flows coming out of Lake Tahoe at around 1 CFS. Yes, that's 1 cubic foot per second. The Upper Truckee River can't really be fished.
特拉基河目前的流量极小，太浩湖流出的流量约为每秒1立方英尺。是的，就是每秒1立方英尺。上特拉基河基本上已经无法钓鱼了。
A week later, they beat that record.
一周后，他们打破了这个记录。
The Truckee River's flows for this week are Tahoe City, 0.1. That's right, less than 0.
本周特拉基河的流量在太浩市是0.1。没错，不到0。
The water is not moving. I was curious if the guy who reads the fishing report noticed how weird it got last year, so we reached out. He was glad to talk. He's the kind of old-school DJ who goes by one name on the air, and that name is Dondo. Off the air, he also has a last name-- Darue. Dondo says he definitely noticed how out there The Fishing Report got last year when the water flows dropped so quickly. He'd never seen water flows get that low. Then the forests were closed down to fishing, which had never happened for so long.
水流不动了。我很好奇去年读钓鱼报告的那个人是否注意到了去年变得多么古怪，所以我们联系了他。他很乐意交谈。他是那种在广播中只用一个名字的传统DJ，那个名字叫 Dondo。在广播外，他还有一个姓氏——Darue。Dondo说，他确实注意到了去年当水流量下降得如此之快时，钓鱼报告变得多么离谱。他从未见过水流量降得那么低。然后森林关闭禁止钓鱼，这在以前从未持续这么长时间。
And then on top of that, we had a series of catastrophic fires last year. And it all sort of played its way through The Fishing Report. And you get the information, and I want to make it upbeat and interesting. But reading the raw copy, I would go, oh man. How-- ugh. You know?
最重要的是，我们去年经历了一系列灾难性的火灾。这一切都以某种方式体现在了钓鱼报告中。虽然我得到了这些信息，并且想让它变得乐观有趣，但读着原始文稿，我会想，天哪，怎么会……唉。你知道吗？
Yeah. So what do you do to make it upbeat? Because you definitely make it upbeat.
是的。那你怎么做才能让它听起来乐观？因为你确实把它变得很乐观。
Well, it helps to have a music bed [LAUGHS] that's kind of upbeat. And although it is hard sometimes when everything's on fire and COVID variants are spreading like crazy and you're trying to be upbeat, like oh, and here's the new Weezer.
嗯，这离不开一段比较欢快的背景音乐（笑）。虽然有时候一切都在燃烧，新冠变异病毒疯狂传播，而你试图表现得积极向上，比如“哦，这里有新歌Weezer”，这确实很难。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
It's kind of hard to make that transition.
这种转变有点困难。
Yeah. It's kind of scarier because you're so cheerful about it. It's almost like it's scarier because we've adapted, you know what I mean?
是的。你表现得如此欢快，反而更让人害怕。这几乎就像我们已经适应了这种情况，你明白我的意思吗？
Yeah. I never really thought about that, but I think you're right. There are plenty of times-- thankfully, it's radio-- when you go into something and you turn the microphone off and I just rest my forehead in my hand and go, oh man.
是的。我从来没真正想过这个问题，但我认为你是对的。有很多次——谢天谢地，这只是广播——当我完成一段录音，关掉麦克风后，我只能把额头靠在手上说，噢天哪。
There's been a lot of that this last year. Dondo doesn't just do the fishing report on 101.5. He's also the DJ during morning drivetime, three hours every weekday. And he says he tries to keep it lighter because they're a music station. People aren't coming to them for the news, really. He's been doing radio 42 years. He's older than anybody else at the station. Calls his daily show "Yesterday's Morning Show of Tomorrow Today," which maybe gives you a feeling for his sense of humor.
去年有很多这样的时刻。Dondo 不仅在 101.5 播报钓鱼报告。他还是早高峰时段的 DJ，每个工作日三个小时。他说他尽量保持轻松，因为他们是一个音乐电台。人们来收听并不是为了看新闻。他做广播已经42年了。他是电台里年纪最大的人。他把自己的每日节目称为“昨日的明日早间秀，就在今天”，这或许能让你感受到他的幽默感。
He does fish himself, but he only went out once last season. It was hard living around Truckee and Tahoe last summer. It's a place where lots of houses don't have AC, and because of the air quality, you were supposed to stay inside with the windows closed during unusually hot days and nights of almost no rain. Then the Caldor fire got close to them with so much smoke. And at its worst, it was like twilight in the middle of the day.
他自己也钓鱼，但上一季他只出去了那么一次。去年夏天在特拉基和太浩附近生活很艰难。这里许多房子都没有空调，而且因为空气质量原因，在那些极度炎热且几乎没有雨水的日子和夜晚，你应该待在室内并紧闭窗户。后来卡尔多大火离他们很近，浓烟滚滚。最糟糕的时候，白天就像黄昏一样。
When the wind shifted, Dondo says, you could taste what was being burned. It was hard to sleep at night, even with three air purifiers they bought for their house. Dondo's lived in the area most of his life and said he's never been so frightened that they'd lose their home.
当风向改变时，Dondo 说，你可以尝到空气中焚烧的味道。即使他们为家里买了三台空气净化器，晚上也很难入睡。Dondo 在这个地区生活了大半辈子，他说他从未如此害怕他们会失去家园。
It was scary. The fear was really palpable. And I tried not to talk about it much around my kids-- they're 10 and 14-- because they were frightened by it, as well. When you can't see anything, you know what's going on. And my son, who's our youngest, he would ask me about every other day, Dad, where do we go if we get evacuated?
这很可怕。恐惧感确实非常强烈。我尽量不在孩子们面前多提这件事——他们分别是10岁和14岁——因为他们也对此感到害怕。当你什么都看不见时，你就知道发生了什么。我的儿子，我们最小的孩子，几乎每隔一天就会问我：“爸爸，如果我们被疏散，我们去哪里？”
And we put yellow dots, little yellow, sticky dots on everything in the house that if we had time, we would grab and throw in the car.
于是我们在家里所有东西上都贴了黄色圆点，如果还有时间，我们就抓起这些东西扔进车里。
Yeah.
是的。
It was really kind of apocalyptic, in a way. One of the things I would say on the air was like, oh, we have another Martian sunrise today. And just this orange-- the sun was just a colored ball that kind of came up over the horizon.
这在某种程度上确实有点世界末日的感觉。我在广播里说过的一句话是，哦，今天我们又迎来了一次火星式的日出。就是这种橘色——太阳在地平线上升起，只是一个有颜色的圆球。
Do you feel like that's kind of snuck up on you these last few years, this apocalyptic feeling?
你是否觉得这几年这种世界末日的感觉悄悄找上了你？
Yeah, to the point where it seems like, well, this is how it's going to be every year.
是的，甚至到了这样一种程度：好吧，似乎每年都会这样。
This apocalyptic feeling that so many of us have, it's not the kind of apocalypse that happens in an instant, like nuclear bombs going off or, I don't know, aliens invading. It's climate change, so it's slow. Dondo says, in previous years, he definitely noticed summers getting hotter, longer stretches without rain or snow. And then finally, it feels like we're past a tipping point. Or maybe we're not. It's hard to be sure. It's like apocalypse creep, the end of the world that we know oozing up around us, one hot day at a time.
我们许多人都有这种世界末日的感觉，但它不是那种瞬间发生的末日，比如核弹爆炸或外星人入侵。这是气候变化，所以它是缓慢的。Dondo 说，在过去几年里，他确实注意到夏天变得更热，没有雨雪的时间拉长了。终于，感觉我们越过了一个临界点。也许我们没有。很难确定。这就像末日潜行，我们所知的世界正在一点点渗向毁灭，每一天都变得更加炎热。
Today on our program, we have stories of people in what seems like, from the outside, pretty extreme situations. And they have to decide to notice the creep or to ignore it, to act or not to act. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要讲述那些从外部看起来似乎处于相当极端情况下的人们的故事。他们必须决定是去注意这种潜行的末日，还是无视它，是去行动还是不行动。请继续收听。
Act one, Apocalypse Now-ish.
第一幕，末日现世。
[MUSIC - MALVINA REYNOLDS, "LITTLE BOXES"]
（音乐 - MALVINA REYNOLDS，“LITTLE BOXES”）
(SINGING) Little boxes on the hillside, little boxes made of ticky-tacky. Little boxes on the hillside, little boxes all the same.
（歌唱）山坡上的小房子，用廉价材料建成。山坡上的小房子，全都一模一样。
Pacifica, California, is a community of about 40,000 people on the ocean just south of San Francisco. This song that you're hearing, "Little Boxes," it was written about the tract housing that was thrown up in neighboring Daly City after the Second World War. Those same tract houses went up in Pacifica.
加利福尼亚州的帕西菲卡是一个位于旧金山以南海边的社区，大约有4万人。你刚才听到的这首歌《小盒子》，是关于二战后在邻近的戴利城匆忙建起的成片住宅。同样的住宅也建在了帕西菲卡。
(SINGING) There's a pink one and a green one and a blue one and a yellow one. And they're all made out of ticky tacky and they all look just the same.
（歌唱）有一个粉红色的，一个绿色的，一个蓝色的，还有一个黄色的。它们都是由廉价材料建成的，看起来全都一模一样。
Those tract houses are actually pretty nice, even if they are the same. And these days, there are newer, fancier houses, too. Some tech types have moved in. But Pacifica is still mostly middle class, about 20% Asian, 20% Latino, 60% white, a beach town with famously great surfing and a Taco Bell that people call the world's most beautiful Taco Bell. But Pacifica is struggling with their own slow-moving apocalypse. Alix Spiegel explains.
这些成片的房子其实还不错，即使它们一模一样。如今，这里也有更新、更豪华的房子。一些科技界人士也搬了进来。但帕西菲卡主要还是中产阶级，约20%是亚裔，20%是拉美裔，60%是白人。这是一个海滩小镇，以著名的冲浪圣地而闻名，还有一个被人们称为世界上最美丽的塔可钟餐厅。但帕西菲卡正在与他们自己缓慢移动的末日作斗争。艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔对此进行了解释。
For the first seven years after Jane moved in, everything about her house was normal. The building itself wasn't particularly impressive. It was a modest three-bedroom cottage. But that worked fine for a single mom like her. And since the house had been built high on a cliff in the city of Pacifica, her view of the ocean was spectacular.
简搬进来后的头七年，关于她房子的事情一切都很正常。建筑本身并没有什么特别之处。这是一栋朴素的三居室小屋。但对于像她这样的单亲妈妈来说，这已经足够了。由于房子建在帕西菲卡市的一处悬崖高处，她看海的视野非常壮观。
Jane had always wanted to live by the sea. So even though the house had drained every cent from her bank account, for Jane, it was worth it. Every night, she fell asleep to the sound of crashing waves. Or anyway, that was how it went for seven gloriously normal years until one February morning in 1998.
简一直想住在海边。所以，即使房子花光了她银行账户里的每一分钱，对简来说，这也值了。每天晚上，她都在海浪声中入睡。总之，七年里一切都正常得让人愉快，直到1998年的一个二月早晨。
My bedroom was right on the ocean. It opened out onto the lovely little patio with a sliding glass door. And I was in the bedroom in my queen-size bed, sat up, and my backyard was gone.
我的卧室就在海边。它通向一个可爱的带推拉玻璃门的小露台。当时我正躺在特大号床上，坐起来，发现我的后院没了。
It was so strange. When Jane had gone to bed the night before, everything about the back of her house had been in order. And Jane's backyard was pretty big, not the kind that usually disappears in the middle of the night.
这太奇怪了。简前一天晚上睡觉时，房子后面的情况一切正常。而且简的后院很大，通常不会在半夜消失。
It had a patio in the back that was maybe eight feet wide. Then it had ice plant that was maybe 25 feet. Then there was a fence that was really sturdy. And then on the other side of the fence, there was another eight, 10 feet.
后面有一个大约八英尺宽的露台。然后有大约25英尺的冰叶日中花。然后是一道非常坚固的篱笆。篱笆另一边还有八到十英尺。
Jane couldn't understand it. It had rained the day before, but during the night, there'd been no storm, no wind, no earthquake. Maybe she was stuck in some strange life-like dream?
简无法理解。前一天下过雨，但夜里没有暴风雨，没有大风，也没有地震。难道她陷入了某种奇怪的真实梦境？
It wouldn't register, and I went out of my bedroom and into the kitchen and kind of looked out the window, back at my bedroom, and realized that part of the bedroom was not attached to anything. The cliff was gone.
我无法接受，我走出卧室进了厨房，从窗户往回看我的卧室，才意识到卧室的一部分并没有连接任何东西。悬崖消失了。
Was it literally like the sea crashing beneath your house?
真的是大海在你房子下面冲刷吗？
Yes. Yea, it was. My house was essentially-- at least the bedroom part of it-- was hanging pretty much in midair.
是的，没错。我的房子本质上——至少是卧室部分——基本上悬在半空中。
Looking back through her kitchen window at her now precariously dangling bedroom, the problem was perfectly obvious. The 70-foot-tall cliff which had supported her house had quietly slid into the ocean while she slept.
透过厨房窗户看着现在摇摇欲坠的卧室，问题显而易见。支撑她房子的70英尺高的悬崖在睡梦中悄无声息地滑进了大海。
Just kind of went, ooh, gently into the sea.
就这样轻轻地，噢，滑入了海里。
Jane knew 1998 was an El Niño year, which meant stronger storms and currents in her part of northern California. She also knew that stronger currents would eat away at the bluffs beneath her house more quickly. But Jane and her neighbors hadn't been worried. Sure, in theory, El Niño could cause their homes to tumble into the ocean. But in their experience, theory rarely translated into practice, so it didn't seem real. In fact, two weeks earlier, Jane had had the whole street over for a raucous El Niño party.
简知道1998年是厄尔尼诺年，这意味着她在北加州的这一地区会有更强的风暴和海流。她也知道更强的海流会更快地侵蚀她房子下方的断崖。但简和她的邻居们并不担心。当然，理论上，厄尔尼诺可能导致他们的家园跌入大海。但在他们的经验中，理论很少转化为现实，所以这看起来并不真实。事实上，两周前简还邀请整条街的人举办了一场狂欢的厄尔尼诺派对。
And I told everybody to come, bring something, and wear flotation devices. So everybody had on water rings, inner tubes, you know, life jackets.
我告诉大家一定要来，带点什么东西，并穿上漂浮装置。所以每个人都戴着水圈、内胎，你知道，救生衣。
Jane had worn a necklace of rubber duckies strung around her neck and carried a huge drink for most of the night. Together, they all drank and danced and laughed, secure in the knowledge that, though nature might be hazardous for some, they, themselves, were safe.
简脖子上挂着一串橡皮鸭项链，大部分时间都拿着一大杯饮料。他们一起喝酒、跳舞、大笑，心中笃定地认为，虽然大自然可能对某些人来说是危险的，但他们自己是安全的。
It was a great party.
那是个很棒的派对。
But then here they were, two short weeks later, and the laughably distant threat they'd mocked suddenly wasn't as laughably distant. Not to Jane, and not to any of her neighbors.
但两周后，他们嘲笑的那种看似遥远的威胁突然变得不再那么遥远了。对简来说是这样，对她的邻居们来说也是如此。
Down the block, the same thing was happening. Everybody was losing their backyards. The guy next door to me lost-- his hot tub went over that was in his backyard. The other side of me, she lost her back porch. So there was 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9--
街区那边，同样的事情也在发生。每个人都在失去后院。我旁边的邻居失去了后院的按摩浴缸。另一边，失去了后门廊。所以当时有1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8、9——
In the end, 10 houses had to be abandoned. Today, there are only odd-numbered houses on Jane's old street. I know this may seem like an extreme example, but most of us are living some version of this story, dancing and drinking as the world under our feet disappears. I certainly am. It's like we know something bad is coming, but it's so far away, and look, alcohol.
最后，10所房子不得不被废弃。今天，简的老街上只剩下奇数门牌号的房子了。我知道这看起来可能是一个极端的例子，但我们大多数人都在经历这个故事的某个版本，当脚下的世界消失时，我们依然在跳舞和饮酒。我当然也是。就像我们知道坏事即将发生，但它太遥远了，看，这还有酒精呢。
I mean, we looked hysterical coming up the block.
我是说，我们沿着街走上来的时候看起来真是歇斯底里。
The problems and temptations of now feel very pressing. The maybe possible future, very far away and unlikely to happen in our actual lifetime, until one day, when suddenly, the future is here and there's not much to do but take inventory.
当下的问题和诱惑感觉非常紧迫。那可能出现的未来，感觉非常遥远，不太可能在我们的实际有生之年发生，直到有一天，突然间，未来到来了，除了清点损失，别无他法。
Oh my god, the patio's gone. The picnic table's gone. The ice plant's gone.
天哪，露台没了。野餐桌没了。冰叶日中花没了。
Certainly, that's how it had been in the city of Pacifica for decades, because I got to tell you, this issue of houses in the city of Pacifica disappearing into the sea, that got started long before Jane Tollini woke up to a world without a backyard.
当然，帕西菲卡市几十年来一直都是这样，因为我得告诉你，帕西菲卡市的房屋消失在海里的问题，早在简·托里尼在没有后院的世界中醒来之前就已经开始了。
We've had dramatic video out of Pacifica for the past couple of weeks. It's not getting any better, the situation there. Cliff erosion--
过去几周，我们看到了帕西菲卡令人震惊的视频。情况没有好转，悬崖侵蚀——
Many date the beginning to 1983, when the ocean swallowed the old Neiland house, a small cottage close to the beach in a neighborhood called Sharp Park. For a while after that, there was just a smattering of disappearances-- a house here, a house there. You hardly even noticed. But then around 2010, whole apartment buildings began to falter and news outlets from all over the world came to Pacifica to gawk.
许多人将这一开端追溯到1983年，当时大海吞噬了旧尼兰德住宅，这是一个位于夏普公园社区靠近海滩的小屋。那之后的一段时间里，只是零星地消失了一些房子，这里一个，那里一个。你几乎都没注意到。但大约在2010年，整栋公寓楼开始摇摇欲坠，来自世界各地的新闻媒体来到帕西菲卡围观。
Clinging onto the edge of the Pacifica cliffs, these blocks of flats and houses won't be standing for much longer.
这些公寓楼和房屋紧紧抓住帕西菲卡的悬崖边缘，它们撑不了多久了。
Over the years, at least 31 homes and three apartment buildings were lost, a surreal horror movie in extremely slow motion. But few people in town were alarmed by what was happening. In fact, in an eerie kind of Stepford wife-ish way, most weren't alarmed at all. I heard that from resident after resident.
多年来，至少有31所住宅和三栋公寓楼消失了，这是一部极其缓慢的超现实恐怖电影。但镇上很少有人对正在发生的事情感到惊慌。事实上，以一种令人毛骨悚然的类似《复制娇妻》的方式，大多数人根本不担心。我从一个又一个居民那里听到了这一点。
No, not really. The town has never seemed alarmed by it.
不，并没有。这个小镇似乎从未对此感到惊慌。
We almost couldn't get them to pay attention, you know? I would say the only people who were worried about the actual houses and apartments were the people who lived there.
我们几乎无法让他们关注，你知道吗？我会说唯一担心房子和公寓本身的人就是住在那里的人。
It was oh, another anomaly. Too bad. There's some shock about bits and pieces breaking off, but then you settle back into what's normal.
这只是“哦，又是异常情况。太糟糕了”。对于某些碎片断裂会有一些震惊，但随后你又回到了正常状态。
But then around 2018, something happened that many residents of Pacifica did find very alarming. It wasn't anything as flashy as a house or apartment building disappearing into the surf. It was a seemingly innocuous instruction nestled in an obscure guidance document put out by the California Coastal Commission, a small but powerful state agency whose job is to oversee land development along the coast.
但大约在2018年，发生了一件许多帕西菲卡居民确实感到非常惊慌的事情。这并不像房子或公寓楼掉进海里那样耀眼。这是加州海岸委员会发布的一份晦涩难懂的指导文件中嵌入的一条看似无害的指令，这是一个小巧但功能强大的州机构，其工作是监督沿海的土地开发。
The language was dense and technical. But once you parsed it, the message was clear-- people in the city of Pacifica were being asked to pause their dancing, put down their drinks, and for one moment, stand and consider what to do about the creeping apocalypse that threatened the fate of their city.
语言密度很高且具有技术性。但一旦你仔细研读，信息就很明确——帕西菲卡市的人们被要求暂停跳舞，放下饮料，片刻间站出来，考虑一下如何应对威胁他们城市命运的潜行末日。
Can you just read, like, those first two paragraphs?
你能读一下那前两段吗？
Actually out loud?
真的要大声读出来吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Ah, OK. So this is from the state of California, "Sea Level Rise Guidance."
啊，好的。那么，这是来自加州政府的《海平面上升指导》。
John Keener was mayor of Pacifica in 2018 when this whole thing blew up. On my second day in town, we sat in the living room of the home that he and his wife Kathleen share, a cream-colored tract house built in a part of town very far from the sea. Together in the morning light, we read through the bureaucratic guidance that had so unsettled his city.
约翰·基纳是2018年事态爆发时帕西菲卡的市长。在我到访的第二天，我们坐在他和妻子凯瑟琳共享的住宅的客厅里，这是一栋建在远离大海的城市区域的奶油色住宅。在晨光中，我们一起阅读了那份让他的城市如此不安的官僚指导。
Climate change is upon us, affecting almost every facet of California's natural and built environment.
气候变化已经到来，影响着加州自然和建筑环境的几乎每一个方面。
Ooh, actually, will you read a little bit slower so that people can understand?
噢，其实，你能读得慢一点吗，好让人们能听懂？
OK. Climate change is upon us.
好的。气候变化已经到来。
Now, houses falling into the ocean, that's a thing that will happen when you build them on cliffs, just due to erosion. What the Commission was saying was that the problem was really going to accelerate in the coming decades because of sea level rise. The higher water would lead to more erosion and the warmer water would lead to more storms, which would also lead to more erosion.
现在，房子掉进海里，那是当你把它们建在悬崖上时，仅仅由于侵蚀就会发生的事情。委员会所说的是，由于海平面上升，这个问题在未来几十年内真的会加速。更高的水位会导致更多的侵蚀，更暖的水温会导致更多的风暴，这也会导致更多的侵蚀。
According to scientists with the US Geological Survey, over the next 80 years, around half a million California homes could be impacted. Another study found that by 2050, around $10 billion worth of property in the state could, quote, "be underwater."
据美国地质调查局的科学家称，在未来80年内，加州约有50万所房屋可能受到影响。另一项研究发现，到2050年，该州价值约100亿美元的房产可能，引用，“被淹没”。
Now, the arrival of this dark future would be uneven. For some places on the coast, it might be 10 years. For others, it could be 30, 40, 50. But the commission was sure that sea level rise was coming and it wasn't going to be good, so it wanted cities to create an official plan for dealing with this problem. Essentially, they wanted every city to identify all of the places in their community where sea level rise would have negative impacts, then choose from this menu of strategies that are frequently used to deal with rising and more violent water. Stuff like putting houses on stilts or constructing massive seawalls that can act as a barrier and keep ocean water from eating away at the land.
现在，这个黑暗未来的到来将是不均衡的。对于海岸上的某些地方，可能是10年。对其他人来说，可能是30、40、50年。但委员会确定海平面上升即将来临，而且不会是什么好事，所以它希望各城市制定应对这一问题的官方计划。本质上，他们希望每个城市都能识别社区中海平面上升会产生负面影响的所有地点，然后从这些经常用于应对不断上涨和更猛烈水势的策略菜单中进行选择。比如把房子建在高脚架上，或者建造巨大的海堤，作为屏障，防止海水吞噬土地。
And this is where the issue began, because one of the strategies the Commission wanted communities to consider was this thing called managed retreat.
而问题就是从这里开始的，因为委员会希望社区考虑的策略之一是被称为“管理后撤”的东西。
Retreat. Retreat strategies are those strategies that relocate or remove existing development out of hazard areas and limit the construction of new development in vulnerable areas.
后撤。后撤策略是指那些将现有开发项目从危险区域迁出或拆除，并限制在脆弱地区进行新开发的策略。
Basically, the idea is that the government pays people to move or physically lift their houses off the ground and relocate them. You just get houses out of the way and don't build more in places where seawater will become an overwhelming problem. That way, people don't wake up one morning, as Jane did--
基本理念是政府付费让人们搬迁，或者从物理上把房子吊离地面并迁走。你只需要把房子从不合适的地方移走，并停止在海水将成为压倒性问题的地方进行建设。这样，人们就不会像简那样，某天早上醒来——
My backyard was gone.
我的后院没了。
--to their bedroom dangling over the wide, crashing sea.
——发现自己的卧室悬在广阔、冲刷的大海上。
To be honest with you, I went, holy shit.
老实说，我当时觉得，该死。
Now, the economic arguments for managed retreat can be appealing to a town like Pacifica, which doesn't have much money. See, often, to protect houses like Jane's from the ocean, you have to spend millions building a seawall or some other barrier that stops the water. Then you have to spend millions more to maintain it, because the ocean will eat away at the wall.
现在，管理后撤的经济论点对于像帕西菲卡这样没什么钱的小镇来说可能很有吸引力。看，通常为了保护像简那样的房子免受海洋侵蚀，你必须花费数百万美元建造海堤或其他阻止海水的屏障。然后你还得花费数百万美元去维护它，因为海水会不断侵蚀墙体。
Another mark against seawalls is that seawalls, which are built on land near the water, always end up killing beaches. Unless you trek in massive amounts of sand every couple years, which is expensive, the water washes the sand away until the water is hitting the wall itself. Ergo, no more beaches. And a big part of the Commission's job is to protect California's iconic beaches.
反对海堤的另一个理由是，建在水边土地上的海堤总是会杀死海滩。除非你每隔几年就运进大量的沙子，这很昂贵，否则海水会把沙子冲走，直到海水直接撞击墙体本身。因此，就不会再有海滩了。而委员会的主要工作之一就是保护加州标志性的海滩。
Now, to be clear, there are plenty of situations where building some sort of barrier against the ocean makes economic sense-- say, a densely populated area. There, yes, a seawall is expensive, but you're protecting lots of homes and businesses. That's why the Coastal Commission was asking Pacifica to study and evaluate managed retreat on a neighborhood-by-neighborhood basis.
现在，明确地说，在很多情况下，建造某种阻挡海洋的屏障是有经济意义的——比如说，人口稠密的地区。在那里，是的，海堤很贵，但你保护了大量的住房和企业。这就是为什么海岸委员会要求帕西菲卡在邻里基础上研究和评估管理后撤。
For his part, John saw no harm in looking at managed retreat as an option, especially since the Commission wasn't demanding the town actually choose managed retreat or anything.
就他而言，约翰认为把管理后撤作为一个选项没什么坏处，尤其是因为委员会并没有要求该镇真的选择管理后撤。
It definitely wasn't saying that they had to do it. This was a guidance, but they wanted Pacifica to study it, to consider managed retreat.
它绝对不是说他们必须这样做。这只是一个指导，但他们想让帕西菲卡研究它，考虑管理后撤。
So in early 2018, the city started putting together a plan to submit to the California Coastal Commission. They hired engineering consultants to take measurements along the coast, analyze which neighborhoods would be hardest hit and when that hitting might occur. Then John and the consultants presented those findings in a series of public meetings meant to educate the public and get feedback.
所以2018年初，该市开始制定计划提交给加州海岸委员会。他们聘请了工程顾问对海岸进行测量，分析哪些社区受到的打击最大以及何时可能发生。然后约翰和顾问们在一系列旨在教育公众和获取反馈的公开会议上展示了这些发现。
Welcome to another workshop on planning for sea level rise. I'm John Keener, mayor of Pacifica.
欢迎参加关于规划海平面上升的研讨会。我是帕西菲卡市长约翰·基纳。
In the meetings, the scientists and engineers laid out all of the options-- how they all worked, what they would cost. For some sections of town, it was clear seawalls made the most sense. For others, the consultants explained that managed retreat might be a smart option. But almost immediately, it became clear that there were citizens in Pacifica who thought managed retreat was a terrible idea. They didn't even want to consider it and were disturbed that managed retreat was on the table as an option at all.
在会议上，科学家和工程师提出了所有选项——它们如何运作，成本是多少。对于镇上的某些区域，很明显海堤是最合理的。对于其他人，顾问们解释说管理后撤可能是一个明智的选择。但几乎立即，很明显帕西菲卡有公民认为管理后撤是一个糟糕的主意。他们甚至不想考虑它，并且对于管理后撤被作为选项摆在台面上感到不安。
Please don't destroy my house, which is the only thing I have.
请不要毁掉我的房子，那是我唯一拥有的东西。
My concern is that it's all going to be taken away from me by something that may or may not happen in the future. That's not right.
我担心的是，所有的一切都会被未来可能发生或不发生的事情夺走。那是不对的。
This all kind of bothers me, and things are really confusing.
这一切让我感到困扰，事情真的让人很困惑。
People were really upset. In fact, eventually, the meetings got so intense that police were asked to attend so things didn't get out of hand. People were demanding that the mayor stand up to the Coastal Commission and say no, categorically reject even the consideration of managed retreat. Will you do that, they asked their mayor, John Keener? Will you?
人们非常愤怒。事实上，最终，会议变得如此紧张，以至于警察被要求出席，以防场面失控。人们要求市长挺身而出，对抗海岸委员会，断然拒绝甚至考虑管理后撤。你会那样做吗，他们问他们的市长约翰·基纳？你会吗？
Excuse me, but you want--
对不起，但你想要——
OK, answer--
好了，回答——
Answer the question!
回答问题！
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
God. You said it was question and answer.
天哪。你说过这是问答环节。
Sir, I understand. But we've got to keep our cool here, OK?
先生，我明白。但我们得保持冷静，好吗？
That frustrated man shouting "answer the question" is a resident named Jeff Guillet. Jeff is not the kind of person who typically raises his voice in public meetings. In fact, before 2018, he'd never been to a city council meeting and didn't even know the mayor's name. I wanted to talk to Jeff so I could better understand the concerns around managed retreat. And he agreed, but admitted that he was a little wary.
那个喊着“回答问题”的沮丧男人名叫杰夫·吉莱特。杰夫通常不是那种在公共会议上大声喧哗的人。事实上，在2018年之前，他从未参加过市议会会议，甚至不知道市长的名字。我想和杰夫谈谈，这样我能更好地理解围绕管理后撤的担忧。他同意了，但承认自己有点谨慎。
I have done several interviews in the last couple of years. And every time that it's done, it was done with the sensational part of Pacifica cliffs falling into the ocean and such, and oh my gosh, isn't this terrible. And I've been painted as a climate-change denier, which is completely not true.
过去几年我接受过几次采访。每次采访时，都伴随着帕西菲卡悬崖落入大海之类的耸人听闻的画面，哎呀，这不是很可怕吗。我被描绘成一个气候变化否定者，这完全不是事实。
Jeff Guillet is not a climate denier. He believes climate change is real. These days, Jeff is an IT professional who's solidly middle class. But when he and his wife Amy set out to buy a home in Pacifica in 1993, they weren't exactly dripping in money. Jeff was an office manager at a copy machine company and Amy worked a job in truck leasing.
杰夫·吉莱特不是气候否定者。他相信气候变化是真实的。如今，杰夫是一名IT专业人士，属于稳固的中产阶级。但当他和妻子艾米1993年打算在帕西菲卡买房时，他们手头并不宽裕。杰夫当时是一家复印机公司的办公室经理，艾米在一家卡车租赁公司工作。
At the time, it was macaroni and cheese and Top Ramen. And it was definitely a stretch.
那时候，我们吃的是通心粉、奶酪和日式拉面。这绝对是一笔很吃力的开支。
But then they saw the ranch house on Seaside Drive, a compact, 1950s rectangle painted yellow. And instantly, they could imagine raising a family there. The floor plan was identical to the ranch where Jeff grew up. Also, the house, though not on the ocean, was within walking distance of the water. So Jeff and Amy pulled money out of some retirement accounts, got a gift from an uncle, and made the $20,000 down payment.
但后来他们看到了海滨大道上的那栋牧场式住宅，这是一个紧凑的、1950年代的黄色矩形房屋。他们立刻就能想象在那里抚养一个家庭。平面图和他长大的牧场式房子一模一样。而且，房子虽然不在海边，但步行即可到达水边。所以杰夫和艾米从一些退休账户中取出钱，接受了叔叔的赠款，支付了2万美元的首付。
And it was like, wow. This is great.
当时的感觉是，哇。太棒了。
So when you first came, had you heard anything about the sea and houses, structures?
那么当你刚来的时候，你听说过任何关于大海和房子、结构的事情吗？
It was never something that was on the radar that it was ever going to be an issue.
那从来不是什么值得关注的问题。
Yeah. We're a quarter of a mile from the beach, so sea level rise wasn't a thing. I didn't think about flooding or anything like that, because we're just-- we're so far away from it, it didn't directly affect us.
是的。我们距离海滩四分之一英里，所以海平面上升根本不是一回事。我没想过洪水之类的东西，因为我们距离它太远了，它并没有直接影响我们。
The first time Jeff heard the words "managed retreat" was in the summer of 2018 when he came home from work and found a yellow flyer stuffed through a gap in his gate.
杰夫第一次听到“管理后撤”这个词是在2018年夏天，当时他下班回家，发现一张黄色传单塞在他大门的缝隙里。
Show me the flyer?
给我看看传单？
Yeah. OK, so this is the homeowner alert, sea level rise, local coastal program, managed retreat.
是的。好的，这是一个房主警报，关于海平面上升、地方海岸规划和管理后撤。
The flyer, which had been printed by a local realtor association, explained the basics of managed retreat. And to Jeff, some of the information provided sounded pretty alarming.
这张由当地房地产经纪人协会印制的传单解释了管理后撤的基本知识。对于杰夫来说，提供的一些信息听起来非常令人震惊。
In light of projected sea level rise, the city of Pacifica will be considering a managed retreat, which could involve removing resources from the coast, including utilities and roads, removing seawalls, and requiring some owners to tear down their homes and clean their soil at their own expense.
鉴于预测的海平面上升，帕西菲卡市将考虑一种管理后撤，这可能涉及从海岸撤走资源，包括公用事业和道路，拆除海堤，并要求一些房主自费拆除房屋并清理土壤。
Now, the presentation of this information, as one government official wrote to me, is, quote, "inflammatory." Managed retreat does not mean that the city will come into an area and start pulling out roads and houses, as the flyer implies. It's a very slow-moving and voluntary process that unfolds over decades. But Jeff didn't know that. And after reading the flyer, he felt uneasy.
现在，正如一位政府官员写给我的那样，这些信息的呈现方式是“煽动性”的。管理后撤并不意味着城市会进入某个区域并开始拆除道路和房屋，正如传单所暗示的那样。这是一个非常缓慢且自愿的过程，历时数十年。但杰夫不知道这些。看完传单后，他感到不安。
Still, it sounded so outlandish that he basically forgot about it until a couple of days later, when a local man came to clean their carpets.
不过，这听起来太离谱了，所以他基本上忘了这件事，直到几天后，当地一个地毯清洁工来家里清理地毯。
The carpet cleaner, when he came out, we told him, this is-- he said, these carpets are pretty old. And I said, yeah, we're going to replace them. We're going to put in new hardwood floors and such. And he said, well, you better do that soon, because with managed retreat, you're not going to be able to make any improvements to your house.
地毯清洁工来的时候，我们告诉他，他说，这些地毯太旧了。我说，是的，我们打算更换它们。我们打算铺设新的硬木地板之类的。他说，好吧，你最好快点，因为有了管理后撤，你将无法对你的房子进行任何改动。
And then it reminded me of this flyer. And so I showed it to him, and he's like, oh, yeah, that's it. You need to look into that.
这让我想起了那张传单。所以我把它拿给他看，他说，哦，是的，就是这个。你需要去调查一下。
So Jeff did look into it, and what he found out distressed him. The engineering consultants hired by the city had determined that Jeff's neighborhood could be considered for managed retreat. The consultants weren't saying that it had to be done tomorrow, or in 25 years or 50 years. They weren't even saying that it had to be done. They were saying that it was a decent option for the future and should be considered.
于是杰夫去调查了，他发现的情况让他感到苦恼。该市聘请的工程顾问已经确定杰夫所在的街区可以被考虑进行管理后撤。顾问们并不是说必须在明天，或者25年或50年内完成。他们甚至不是说必须完成。他们是在说，对于未来这是一个不错的选择，应该被考虑。
But to Jeff, having the label managed retreat anywhere near his neighborhood was a total catastrophe.
但对于杰夫来说，在自己所在的街区附近贴上管理后撤的标签简直是一场灾难。
Managed retreat is basically the city giving up on this land. They've decided--
管理后撤基本上是城市放弃了这块土地。他们决定——
It could mean an increase in insurance rates, denied bank loans. There could be limits on renovations, though it seems like redoing your floors would be totally fine. But without question, the biggest problem for Jeff was this-- publicly saying that a home like his was in a neighborhood where managed retreat was under consideration? That could have an impact on the value of his home.
这意味着保险费率提高，银行贷款被拒绝。可能会对翻修设限，尽管看起来重铺地板是完全可以的。但毫无疑问，对杰夫来说最大的问题是：公开说像他这样的房子所在的街区正在考虑管理后撤？这可能会影响他房子的价值。
Because we would be required to disclose it to future buyers, and who's going to buy a house that's in a hazard zone, that you could potentially lose everything? Who's going to buy that house? Right?
因为我们将被要求向未来的买家披露这一点，谁会买一栋处于危险区、可能会失去一切的房子？谁会买那栋房子？对吧？
So the concern was, if they even say that they are considering this, that, in itself, could be a problem for my housing values.
所以担心的是，如果他们甚至说他们正在考虑这一点，这本身就可能成为我房价的问题。
Right. Correct.
对。正确。
We looked into it, and Jeff wouldn't actually have to disclose that his house was in a hazard zone. But it's true that when you live on the edge of a creeping apocalypse, planning for the future can have some unwelcome financial consequences. That's why Pacifica's homeowners were objecting. They argued that the future, how it would affect their specific home-- the pink one or the green one or the blue one or the yellow one that they lived in-- that was impossible to know.
我们研究了一下，杰夫实际上不需要披露他的房子处于危险区。但确实，当你生活在潜行末日的边缘时，为未来做计划可能会带来一些不受欢迎的经济后果。这就是为什么帕西菲卡的房主们提出反对。他们认为未来，它将如何影响他们特定的家园——他们居住的粉红色、绿色、蓝色或黄色的房子——这是不可能知道的。
Perhaps some tech guru from north of the city would invent a great carbon-sucking machine so we could all go merrily along our way. Who knew?
也许城市北边的一位科技专家会发明一种伟大的吸碳机器，这样我们大家都能快乐地走下去。谁知道呢？
You're going to make me pay now for something that you think might happen in 100 years.
你现在要让我为一个你认为可能在100年后发生的事情买单。
Jeff hates this kind of reasoning.
杰夫讨厌这种推理。
It's, you're delaying the inevitable. We'll just do what's best. It's going to happen anyway. Let's just do it now. And that infuriates me. Let me ask you this. The sun is going to explode. We don't know when. When do we leave the planet? Should we be building rockets right now? Because it's going to happen.
就是“你在延迟不可避免的事情”。我们会做最好的选择。反正迟早会发生。让我们现在就做吧。这让我非常愤怒。让我问你一个问题。太阳会爆炸。我们不知道什么时候。我们什么时候离开地球？我们现在应该造火箭吗？因为它迟早会发生。
Just to say, while both the death of the sun and climate change are scientifically certain, one is happening in 5 billion years. The other, right this minute. But anyway, what Jeff knew was that he and his wife Amy had scrimped and saved, eaten their weight in Top Ramen, for this specific house. And obviously, they didn't want to lose that.
只想说，虽然太阳的死亡和气候变化在科学上都是肯定的，但一个是50亿年后才发生。另一个，就在这一刻。总之，杰夫所知道的是，他和妻子艾米省吃俭用，靠吃拉面度日，才买下了这栋特别的房子。显然，他们不想失去它。
I was worried. I got-- yeah. I couldn't sleep. I'm like, did we make a big mistake? We bought this house. We've invested in it. It's our legacy that we're going to give to our kids when we're gone. And are we at risk of losing everything?
我很担心。我……是的。我无法入睡。我在想，我们犯了一个大错误吗？我们买了这房子。我们投入了它。这是我们要留给孩子们的一份遗产。我们是否面临失去一切的风险？
Night after night, Jeff lay in bed mentally circling the problem.
一天又一天，杰夫躺在床上，在脑海中盘旋着这个问题。
Trying to formulate a plan-- what is it that we're going to do next? How are we going to raise awareness? Is it too late?
试图制定一个计划——接下来我们要做什么？我们该如何提高意识？是不是太晚了？
But then Jeff came up with a plan.
但后来杰夫想出了一个计划。
Alix Spiegel. Coming up after the break, Jeff's plan and a showdown on managed retreat and on who will run Pacifica. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔。休息过后，杰夫的计划，以及关于管理后撤和谁将管理帕西菲卡的较量。稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Apocalypse Creep," stories of the world slowly changing, people deciding what they're going to do with that fact or whether they're going to face it at all. If you're just tuning in, we're in the middle of Alix Spiegel's story about Pacifica, California. A local homeowner, Jeff Guillet, is trying to figure out how to stop all this talk about managed retreat. Again, here's Alix.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《末日潜行》，讲述世界缓慢变化的故事，人们决定如何面对这一事实，或者他们是否愿意面对它。如果你刚调过来，我们正在讲述艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔关于加州帕西菲卡的故事。一位当地房主杰夫·吉莱特正试图弄清楚如何停止所有关于管理后撤的讨论。再次有请艾丽克斯。
Jeff was desperate to defeat managed retreat, so he and a friend did what citizens do. They started knocking on doors, trying to get the word out.
杰夫拼命想打败管理后撤，所以他和朋友做了公民们会做的事。他们开始挨家挨户敲门，试图传达这个消息。
Have you heard of managed retreat? Have you heard what the city is planning, their plan for managed retreat for this area? And invariably, everybody's like, no. What's managed retreat? So you have to explain what managed retreat is.
你听说过管理后撤吗？你听说过这个城市正在计划什么吗，他们针对这个地区的管理后撤计划？每个人总是说，没有。什么是管理后撤？所以你必须解释什么是管理后撤。
It took a huge amount of time. Jeff says he did 40 hours a week, in addition to his 40-hour-a-week job, for months. But he felt he had no choice. His financial security was at stake. All through the summer of 2018, Jeff worked phones and knocked doors, talking about managed retreat. Fortunately, at least from Jeff's perspective, there was an opportunity for a public referendum on managed retreat coming up in the fall-- an election.
这花费了大量时间。杰夫说，除了每周40小时的工作外，他每周还要做40个小时的活动，持续了几个月。但他觉得别无选择。他的经济安全岌岌可危。2018年整个夏天，杰夫都在打电活、敲门，谈论管理后撤。幸运的是，至少从杰夫的角度来看，秋季即将迎来一个关于管理后撤的公民投票机会——选举。
So as he went door to door, one of the things that he talked about was the mayor, John Keener, and how Keener was a supporter of managed retreat. But though Jeff didn't realize it at first, he wasn't the only party interested in raising the alarm about managed retreat and John Keener in Pacifica. The issue had attracted attention from outside the city, as well.
所以当他挨家挨户访问时，他谈论的事情之一就是市长约翰·基纳，以及基纳是如何支持管理后撤的。但虽然杰夫起初没意识到，但他并不是唯一对在帕西菲卡提出关于管理后撤和约翰·基纳的警报感兴趣的政党。这个问题也引起了城市外部的关注。
Real estate groups all up and down the coast of California were flooding Pacifica's elections with money, because like Jeff, they wanted to stop managed retreat in its tracks.
加州沿岸各地的房地产团体都在向帕西菲卡的选举注入资金，因为像杰夫一样，他们想阻止管理后撤的步伐。
My name is Judy Taylor. I have been a realtor on the San Mateo County coast since 1977.
我叫朱迪·泰勒。我从1977年起就是圣马特奥县海岸的一名房地产经纪人。
Judy Taylor is a representative for the San Mateo Association of Realtors. That's the group that created the yellow flyer Jeff found stuffed through a gap in his gate, the flyer that first alerted Jeff to the problem and set him on the road to hundreds of hours of activism. Like Jeff, Judy is not a climate denier. She believes that sea level rise is real, and that inevitably, it will challenge the viability of a large portion of the homes that she and her colleagues now sell.
朱迪·泰勒是圣马特奥房地产经纪人协会的代表。那个团体创造了杰夫在门缝里发现的黄色传单，那张传单最初向杰夫发出了警报，并让他走上了数百小时的行动主义道路。像杰夫一样，朱迪不是气候否定者。她相信海平面上升是真实的，不可避免地，它将挑战她和同事们现在出售的大部分房屋的可行性。
But the answer to this problem, at least from the perspective of a real estate agent like Judy, is not managed retreat, though she admits that some managed retreat will probably have to happen eventually. What real estate agents much prefer is stuff like seawalls. You just have to armor the coastline. Judy says she knows this will be expensive, but she doesn't buy that managed retreat would be cheaper. And so, she says, her organization did whatever it could to convince Pacifica to stand against managed retreat.
但解决这个问题的方法，至少从朱迪这样的房地产经纪人的角度来看，不是管理后撤，尽管她承认最终可能不得不进行一些管理后撤。房地产经纪人更倾向于海堤之类的东西。你只需要加固海岸线。朱迪说她知道这会很昂贵，但她不认为管理后撤会更便宜。所以，她说，她的组织尽其所能说服帕西菲卡抵制管理后撤。
We got people to city council meetings and we had people communicating with the Coastal Commission.
我们让人们参加市议会会议，并与海岸委员会进行交流。
And one of the ways that the realtors brought out residents like Jeff was by telling them that the state was going to take their homes and not give them any money. But when Jeff first brought this up during our interview, I was surprised, because I didn't think that the government could take a house without compensation. So after we talked, I tried to check out the claim.
房地产经纪人带出像杰夫这样的居民的方法之一是告诉他们，政府将夺走他们的房子，而且不给他们任何钱。但当杰夫在我们的采访中提到这一点时，我很惊讶，因为我不认为政府可以在没有补偿的情况下没收房子。所以谈话结束后，我试图核实这个说法。
He said, they're going to take my house and they're not going to give me any money. And I put that in front of the person who used to be the executive director of the California Coastal Commission. And he said, that's against the law. Like, nobody's talking about that. So it's not the case that they're not going to give you any money, right? Like, that's not their actual plan.
他说，他们要夺走我的房子，而且不给我任何钱。我把这话告诉了前加州海岸委员会执行主任。他说，那是违法的。没人在谈论那个。所以并不是说他们不会给你钱，对吧？那不是他们实际的计划。
No, that is their actual plan.
不，那才是他们的实际计划。
It cannot be that they're just going to take the houses. It cannot be that they're just going to take the houses and not get--
不可能他们就这样夺走房子。不可能他们就这样夺走房子而不给——
Alix, it does sound preposterous. But the thing is, they can't buy every vulnerable property.
艾丽克斯，这听起来确实很荒谬。但问题是，他们无法买下每一处脆弱的房产。
In California, she points out, many of the homes that the government would need to buy are multimillion-dollar properties. And Judy just doesn't believe that the government has that kind of cash, couldn't possibly buy out all of those homes and all the Pacifica homeowners and all the other homeowners in all the other places that are threatened.
在加州，她指出，政府需要买下的许多房子都是价值数百万美元的房产。朱迪根本不相信政府有那种现金，根本不可能买下所有这些房子和帕西菲卡的所有房主，以及其他所有受威胁地方的所有其他房主。
Ask them how they plan to do that at the same time Santa Cruz is having its problem, at the same time that Pebble Beach is having a similar problem, at the same time that Monterey is having a problem. This is a massive problem, and there is not enough government money to make all of these property owners whole. I mean, there simply isn't.
问问他们打算如何在圣克鲁兹面临问题的同时做到这一点，同时圆石滩面临类似问题，蒙特雷面临同样问题。这是一个巨大的问题，没有足够的政府资金能弥补所有这些业主。我是说，根本就没有。
Now, California is a big place with a lot of money. And if there were the political will, it could buy out the at-risk houses. In fact, the state legislature recently proposed a way of doing managed retreat that could save a lot of money-- buy the houses, then rent them back to the former residents until sea level rise makes them unusable.
现在，加州是一个拥有大量资金的大地方。如果有政治意愿，它可以买下处于风险中的房子。事实上，州议会最近提出了一种进行管理后撤的方法，可以节省很多钱——买下房子，然后租回给前房主，直到海平面上升使它们无法使用。
But Judy and other realtors are skeptical. And when the election came around in Pacifica, real estate associations from across the state threw a bunch of money at it. According to a local resident named Carlos Davidson, who's tracked Pacifica's election spending, the money spent on Pacifica's 2018 local race was dominated by real estate interests.
但朱迪和其他房地产经纪人对此持怀疑态度。当帕西菲卡进行选举时，来自全州的房地产协会投入了大量资金。据一位跟踪帕西菲卡选举支出的当地居民卡洛斯·戴维森称，帕西菲卡2018年地方选举的支出主要由房地产利益集团控制。
Carlos was one of dozens of residents I spoke to during my reporting in Pacifica. In those conversations, many expressed shock and dismay at how the money that flooded Pacifica altered the tone in the city.
卡洛斯是我在帕西菲卡报道期间采访的几十位居民之一。在那些谈话中，许多人对注入帕西菲卡的资金如何改变了城市的气氛表示震惊和失望。
That was pretty dark, to see that in our small town.
在我们的城镇看到这一点，真是太黑暗了。
For example, Carlos told me that since moving to Pacifica, he had never seen a negative campaign specifically targeting one member of the local government. But in 2018, that changed. Carlos says it was like the realtors were trying to make an example of Mayor John Keener, punish him for saying that he was open to considering managed retreat, so that politicians all over the state would be hesitant to take that stance in the future.
例如，卡洛斯告诉我，自从搬到帕西菲卡，他从未见过专门针对当地政府成员的负面竞选活动。但在2018年，情况变了。卡洛斯说，好像房地产经纪人想拿市长约翰·基纳开刀，惩罚他公开表示愿意考虑管理后撤，这样全州的政客在未来都不敢采取那种立场。
Now, there's a certain oddness to John becoming a target. John isn't a firebrand for managed retreat. He's not a firebrand for anything. He's more of a steady grinder than anything else, famous for reading every word of the documents that come before the city council. Even his opponents, like Jeff, describe him as a kind old grandfather figure. But that's not how he was portrayed. Here's Carlos's wife, Cynthia Kaufman.
现在，约翰成为目标有一种奇怪的感觉。约翰不是管理后撤的煽动者。他什么都不是。他更像是一个稳扎稳打的人，以阅读提交给市议会的每一份文件的每一个字而闻名。即使是像杰夫这样的反对者，也形容他是一个慈祥的祖父形象。但人们并不是那样描写他的。这是卡洛斯的妻子辛西娅·考夫曼。
There was a really ugly smear campaign against him, and it was practically every week we got a new mailer that just lied about--
针对他有一场非常丑陋的诽谤运动，几乎每周我们都会收到一份新的邮件，上面都在谎称——
Will you describe what you're holding?
你能描述一下你手里拿着什么吗？
Yeah. So John Keener with his body-- photoshopped to somebody else's body barbecuing money.
是的。所以约翰·基纳的身体——被修图到了别人的身体上在烧钱。
It was a steady bombardment of messages. John Keener wants Pacifica to fall into the ocean. Why is Mayor Keener failing to protect Pacifica? And then there were the signs that flooded into town. Here's John Keener and his wife, Cathleen Josaitis.
这是一场持续的轰炸式信息。约翰·基纳想让帕西菲卡落入海里。基纳市长为什么未能保护帕西菲卡？然后就是涌入城镇的标志牌。这是约翰·基纳和他的妻子凯瑟琳·乔塞蒂斯。
Their symbol was a red circle with a slash through it, like a no parking sign, but said no Keener and his name on it. And they plastered those signs all over town, all over town.
他们的标志是一个红圈中间有一道斜杠，就像一个禁止停车的标志，但写着“拒绝基纳”和他的名字。他们把这些牌子贴满了城镇，贴满了城镇。
They had a sign on a van that they would move around.
他们在一辆面包车上贴了标志，经常到处移动。
It just hurts in the chest to see your family name with a big slash and a circle through it multiple times a day, every day. It was mortifying.
看着你的家庭名字被画上一个大斜杠和圈，每天多次，这在胸口真的好痛。这太丢人了。
Then came the newspaper coverage, a series of searing articles and editorials in The Pacifica Tribune.
然后是新闻报道，在《帕西菲卡论坛报》上的一系列刺痛人心的文章和社论。
Public scorns mayor on managed retreat, gets yelled at in public meeting.
公众藐视市长关于管理后撤的提议，在公开会议上对他大喊大叫。
They came out with pitchforks after John Keener.
他们带着草叉来找约翰·基纳。
Whose side are you on, Mr. Mayor?
你站在哪一边，市长先生？
Pacifica cannot afford managed retreat and Pacifica cannot afford John Keener.
帕西菲卡承担不起管理后撤，帕西菲卡承担不起约翰·基纳。
OK, now read this one.
好了，读这一份。
Ugh.
呃。
Sorry.
对不起。
Yeah, I just don't like reading stuff that says John Keener's a schmuck.
是的，我只是不喜欢读说约翰·基纳是个混蛋的东西。
John says that, despite all of this bad publicity, he felt bullish about keeping his position. He thought that the flyers were so over-the-top, they'd backfire. He told me another council member, someone on the opposite side, felt the same way. She was certain that the loud negative campaign would fail.
约翰说，尽管有所有这些负面宣传，他还是对保住自己的职位感到乐观。他认为传单太夸张了，会适得其反。他告诉我另一位议员，站在对立面的人，也有同样的感受。她坚信那种大声的负面竞选会失败。
She was saying, you're totally going to get re-elected.
她说，你绝对会连任的。
Because Pacificans would see that and say, not in my community? I don't want that kind of-- I don't want that kind of vitriol in my community?
因为帕西菲卡人会看到这些并说，不在我的社区？我不想要那种——我不想要那种在我的社区里恶言恶语？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
But once the numbers started filtering in--
但一旦数字开始陆续公布——
I was in fifth place.
我是第五名。
Wow. Yeah.
哇。是的。
And I wasn't that close to fourth place.
我距离第四名并不近。
It was a resounding defeat.
这是一场惨痛的失败。
I was shocked. I really thought that I would win.
我很震惊。我真的以为我会赢。
John was replaced by a candidate hostile to managed retreat. And by the end of the year, the government finished the process of approving that plan that the California Coastal Commission had asked for. It probably won't surprise you to hear that Jeff and the realtors got what they hoped for.
约翰被一位对管理后撤怀有敌意的候选人取代了。到年底，政府完成了批准海岸委员会所要求的那个计划的过程。当你听到杰夫和房地产经纪人得到了他们想要的，你可能不会感到惊讶。
I actually saw an early draft of what ultimately became that plan when I went to visit a longtime resident named Margaret Goodale. When she pulled it up on her computer, you could see notes and suggestions in the margins, all the changes that were being proposed.
当我去拜访一位老居民玛格丽特·古代尔时，我实际上看到了最终成为该计划的早期草稿。当她在电脑上打开它时，你可以看到页边空白处的备注和建议，所有提议的修改。
--plan for it.
——为它制定计划。
So it says plan for 20 or 30 years, not 100. And then where does it say-- ooh wow. So that's a lot of red lines.
所以它说计划20或30年，而不是100年。然后它在哪里说——噢哇。那有很多红线。
At a certain point as we scrolled down the draft, we encountered what looked like a field of red lines. Wherever there was a neighborhood that had been identified as a hazard area because of sea level rise, it was crossed out. And in the margins, there was a note.
当我们向下滚动草稿时，我们在某一点遇到了看起来像是一片红线的地方。凡是因海平面上升被确定为危险区域的街区，都被划掉了。在页边空白处，有一个备注。
The term hazard has negative doom-and-gloom connotations and is not appropriate. Just because a property exists in the coastal zone does not mean it's in a hazard zone.
“危险”这个词有负面的厄运意味，并不合适。仅仅因为房产位于沿海地带并不意味着它处于危险地带。
And in the final draft, when it came to managed retreat, it was baldly rejected. There was no place in the city of Pacifica for managed retreat, the document stated. And the city didn't anticipate there'd be room for that approach at any point in the near future.
在最终草稿中，当谈到管理后撤时，它被断然拒绝了。文档指出，帕西菲卡市没有进行管理后撤的空间。而且该市预计在不久的将来的任何时候都不会有采用该方法的余地。
Now, some form of managed retreat has been implemented in a bunch of places in red states and blue, usually after a big disaster. But it's much harder when the problem is years in the future. And in California, it's become a political hot potato. Just this past October, Democratic governor Gavin Newsom vetoed a bill that his own legislature had passed, providing money for managed retreat buyouts. Many people speculate it's because the strategy is politically unpopular.
现在，在许多红州和蓝州，在发生重大灾难后，已经实施了某种形式的管理后撤。但当问题是未来几年后的事情时，这就难多了。而在加州，它已经成为一个烫手的政治山芋。就在去年十月，民主党州长加文·纽森否决了州议会通过的一项为管理后撤买断提供资金的法案。许多人推测这是因为该策略在政治上不受欢迎。
It's often politically unpopular to pay now for something that will happen in the future. Paying always hurts, and the benefit of putting it off is that the people in the future aren't around to object or vote. This, of course, is the challenge of climate change in general. The present owns our heart. The future, if it exists for us at all, lives only in our head.
为一个未来才会发生的事情现在买单通常在政治上是不受欢迎的。支付总是令人痛苦，而推迟它的好处是未来的人不在场去反对或投票。当然，这通常是气候变化的挑战。现在占据了我们的心。未来，如果它对我们存在的话，只存在于我们的脑海中。
On my last day in Pacifica, I drove to the north part of town, near the street where Jane's house fell while she slept, to a home on a cliff by the sea. Several years before, the back part of this house had disappeared into the ocean, just like Jane's did. I'd seen a picture, a light blue structure sitting on a large concrete slab that juts awkwardly into thin air.
在帕西菲卡报道的最后一天，我开车去了城镇北边，靠近简的房子在睡梦中掉落的那条街，来到了一栋海边悬崖上的房子。几年前，这栋房子的后部掉进了海里，就像简的那样。我看过一张照片，一个浅蓝色的结构坐落在一个巨大的混凝土板上，尴尬地悬在半空中。
I wanted to see the house because it had been put up for sale. The owners had cleaned up the property, tore off the parts that extended past the edge, and put it on the market for close to a million dollars. I was going to meet the realtor at an open house. On the phone, she said she expected a big crowd. And shortly before 1:00, she pulled up and slid aside the thick metal gate.
我想看看这栋房子，因为它被挂牌出售了。房主清理了房产，拆除了伸出边缘的部分，并以接近一百万美元的价格投放市场。我打算在开放参观日去见房地产经纪人。在电话里，她说她预计会有很多人。在一点前不久，她开车载着我，拉开了厚重的金属门。
Oh, look at that.
噢，看那个。
As interested buyers started filtering in, the realtor seemed a little nervous about the unprotected cliff drop. She'd brought along a rope, which she spooled out about 3 feet away from the edge, and she kept warning people to take heed of it. She wanted people to interpret the line on the ground as an uncrossable boundary.
随着感兴趣的买家开始陆续进入，房地产经纪人看起来对毫无保护的悬崖跌落有点紧张。她带了一根绳子，在距离边缘约3英尺的地方拉开，她不断警告人们要注意。她希望人们把地上的那条线解释为一个不可逾越的边界。
You want to see the cliff, you'll have to go down there. Please don't--
如果你想看悬崖，你得去那边。请不要——
Yeah, we'll go down the other way.
是的，我们走另一边。
Yeah. Please don't go too far. It just makes me nervous.
是的。请不要走得太远。这让我很紧张。
I watched people milling until I saw a middle-aged man and his wife pacing out part of the home, trying to calculate how much ground was left between the ocean-facing garage wall and the drop.
我看着人们徘徊，直到我看到一个中年男子和他的妻子正在测量房子的一部分，试图计算面对海洋的车库墙和悬崖边之间还剩多少土地。
Oh, how close is the garage to the edge?
噢，车库离边缘有多近？
A foot.
一英尺。
1 foot?
1英尺？
Yeah.
是的。
Are you a serious-- are you seriously considering it, or is it just kind of curiosity?
你们是认真的——你们是在认真考虑，还是只是好奇？
No, we are seriously considering it-- I mean, $750,000 for oceanfront. But you've got to consider that cost, too.
不，我们是在认真考虑——我是说，75万美元的海滨房产。但你也得考虑到那个成本。
And what do you think about that? Does it make you nervous at all?
你对此有什么看法？这让你紧张吗？
Well, I think if you put enough and big enough boulders over the side, then it'll slow it down.
嗯，我想如果你在旁边放足够大、足够多的巨石，那就会减慢速度。
Yeah.
是的。
It's inevitable someday that this is going to be in the ocean. [LAUGHS]
总有一天这会掉进海里是不可避免的。（笑）
And so why would you buy a house which you think inevitably will end up in the ocean?
既然你认为它不可避免地会掉进海里，你为什么要买这房子？
Well, for short term, it's for enjoyment, I guess.
嗯，短期来看，我想是为了享受。
How many years do you think you'll get?
你觉得你还能住几年？
Probably more than my lifetime.
可能比我的寿命还长。
For the next two hours, people filtered in and out, oohing and aahing over both the beauty of the structure and the wonder of the sea crashing below on the sand, that thin strip of ground where the present and the future slowly meet.
接下来的两个小时里，人们进进出出，对建筑的美感和下面沙滩上翻涌的大海惊叹不已，那是一片现在与未来缓慢交汇的狭窄土地。
Be careful out there, OK?
在那边小心点，好吗？
Alix Spiegel is one of the producers of our show.
艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Two, resilience is futile. So with the steady drumbeat in our lives of wildfires and floods and storms that are more frequent and more severe, permafrost and glaciers going, what do you do with that? Well, Mario Alejandro Ariza thinks about this stuff all the time because he's a climate reporter for a climate news outlet called Floodlight, and because he lives in Miami, a place where they're already seeing the effects of climate change in very visible, undeniable ways.
第二幕，韧性是徒劳的。所以，伴随着我们生活中愈发频繁和严重的野火、洪水和风暴的稳定鼓点，永久冻土和冰川的消融，你该怎么办？嗯，马里奥·亚历杭德罗·阿里扎一直在思考这些事情，因为他是气候新闻媒体 Floodlight 的气候记者，而且因为他住在迈阿密，一个已经以非常明显、不可否认的方式看到气候变化影响的地方。
In fact, he wrote a book about Miami's doomsday future called Disposable City. But facing all that head on, even he finds that it's hard to know what to think a lot of the time.
事实上，他写了一本关于迈阿密末日未来的书，名叫《一次性城市》。但即使直接面对这一切，他也发现很多时候很难知道该想些什么。
There's a scar on my knuckle in the shape of a star. I got it from punching Alex Rodriguez in the teeth one afternoon in sixth grade. He and 11 other kids had cornered me by the chain-link fence at the end of an empty soccer field. Alex had metal braces that cut my skin open when I swung at him. Then he and all the other kids went at me like a pack of feral dogs.
我指关节上有一道星形的疤痕。这是我在六年级的一个下午因为拳击亚历克斯·罗德里格斯的牙齿而留下的。他和其他11个孩子在空荡荡的足球场尽头的铁丝网边上堵住了我。亚历克斯戴着金属牙套，我打他时割破了我的皮肤。然后他和所有其他孩子像一群野狗一样围攻我。
When I came home badged with bruises, all I offered my parents by way of explanation was that I'd fallen. My silence made sense at the time. I went to an all-boys Catholic school whose official motto was "Men for others," whose unofficial religion was Latin machismo and whose unspoken mantra was [SPANISH]-- don't be a snitch. My peers and elders told me this cruelty was supposed to make me tough, manly. It was supposed to make me resilient.
当我带着瘀伤回家时，我对我父母唯一的解释就是我摔倒了。我的沉默在那时是有道理的。我上的是一所全男生的天主教学校，官方座右铭是“为他人的人”，其非官方宗教是拉丁大男子主义，其不成文的咒语是 [西班牙语] ——别当告密者。我的同龄人和长辈告诉我，这种残酷是为了让我变得强硬、像个男人。这是为了让我变得坚韧。
Alex is an actor now living in Miami and he's also my friend. He's grown into a kind and gentle adult. We grab drinks often. And the older boy who whipped me with a belt that one woeful time now lives in Brooklyn and has founded a tech company. That sadistic motherfucker can burn in hell. But this isn't about settling accounts. Rather, this is about the sun-scorched Miami fields in which I was beaten and their natural tendency to flood.
亚历克斯现在是一名住在迈阿密的演员，他也是我的朋友。他成长为一个善良且温和的成年人。我们经常一起喝一杯。而那个曾经在那次悲惨时刻用皮带抽打我的大男孩现在住在布鲁克林，并创办了一家科技公司。那个虐待狂混蛋可以去地狱。但这与结算账目无关。相反，这是关于我被打的阳光炽热的迈阿密田野以及它们淹水的自然倾向。
You might not think at first that my constantly getting the crap kicked out of me has anything to do with climate change or sea level rise or the death of my city at the hands of an angry, swollen ocean. But that word, resilience-- it's becoming increasingly popular when people talk about climate change in Miami. It means the ability to bounce back quickly, as in what they prescribed to me while I was being hazed and bullied and beaten.
你起初可能不会认为我不断被人痛打与气候变化、海平面上升或我的城市在愤怒、肿胀的海洋手中死去有什么关系。但那个词，“韧性”——当人们在迈阿密谈论气候变化时，它变得越来越流行。它意味着快速反弹的能力，就像我在被欺凌和殴打时他们对我规定的那样。
Now we're being told we have to learn to recover quickly from heat waves, storms, and floods. And we have to do all that, even though we're not sure Miami has another 70 years left in it. By the end of the century, we could witness six feet of sea level rise. The average elevation here is about six feet above sea level. You do the math.
现在人们告诉我们，我们必须学会从热浪、风暴和洪水中快速恢复。我们必须做到所有这一切，尽管我们不确定迈阿密还有没有70年的寿命。到本世纪末，我们可能会见证6英尺的海平面上升。这里的平均海拔大约是海平面以上6英尺。你自己算算吧。
In Miami-Dade County, you can already see this happening. These pulses of water show up. We call them sunny day floods. Didn't have them when I was a kid, and they suck. Under a clear sky, ocean water creeps up from drains like a thief. The bay and the canals that feed into it swell and burst their banks.
在迈阿密-戴德县，你已经可以看到这种情况正在发生。水的脉冲出现了。我们称之为“晴天洪水”。我小时候没有这些，它们糟透了。在晴朗的天空下，海水像小偷一样从排水管中渗出。海湾和汇入其中的运河膨胀并冲破了河岸。
In the low-lying places-- and they are legion in this town-- knee-deep water appears. Whole intersections flood and people plow their cars into them. Traffic snarls. Residents are warned not to wade through their streets if they have any open wounds.
在低洼的地方——在这个城镇里到处都是——出现了齐膝深的水。整个十字路口被淹没，人们把车开进去。交通混乱。居民们被警告，如果有任何开放性伤口，不要涉水穿过街道。
God forbid it rains. Not long ago, I stepped outside of my vet's office with an umbrella in one hand and my kitten in a cat carrier held in the other. It was pouring. And the manhole cover on the sidewalk next to me was doing something weird. It's rattling and moaning. Water was shooting up around it, lifting it up inches into the air, bringing it clanging back down, ringing like the bell of a Gothic cathedral.
老天保佑千万别下雨。不久前，我手里拿着雨伞，另一只手拿着装小猫的猫笼走出兽医办公室。当时正下着大雨。我旁边人行道上的井盖在做一些奇怪的事情。它在响动和呻吟。水在它周围喷涌而出，把它向上推了几英寸，然后又发出叮当声落回，像哥特式大教堂的钟声一样响。
It was late summer, and the tide was so high and there's so much pressure in the stormwater system that the manhole covers up and down the street were coming alive, jumping up out of the sidewalk. Is it safe? Should I run?
那是夏末，潮汐太高了，雨水系统压力太大，街上的井盖一个接一个都活了过来，从人行道上跳了出来。这安全吗？我该跑吗？
Some scientists predict that in just over 20 years from now, we could have hundreds of these floods a year. There is great romance in loving something doomed. Surrender-- [SPANISH] in Spanish-- comes easier when the heartbreak is unavoidable. But my experience with doomed love has taught me that most of the time, it just means a lot of anxiety. It lives in my body like a copper wire wrapped around my shoulder blades.
一些科学家预测，从现在开始只需20多年，我们每年可能会有数百次这样的洪水。热爱注定要毁灭的事物有一种伟大的浪漫。当心碎不可避免时，屈服—— [西班牙语] 在西班牙语中——就变得更容易。但我的注定失败的爱情经历教会我，大多数时候，这只意味着大量的焦虑。它像绕在我肩胛骨上的一根铜线一样存在于我的身体里。
On days when tides are high and the rain is hard, the wire constricts my chest, makes it hard to breathe. It tenses and coils.
在潮汐很高、雨水很大的时候，那根线收紧了我的胸口，让我呼吸困难。它变得紧张和盘旋。
I can be sitting on the toilet scrolling through Instagram when anxiety strikes with a headline announcing that in Europe, regulators will start requiring homes at risk of flooding to disclose their true risk at sale. That doesn't happen here. What if it happened here? Oh my god. Should I sell my house? I have a moment like this, on average, once a day. The friends I text or call about it are tired of hearing me kvetch. Where would you go if you sold, Mario? Orlando? You hate Orlando.
当焦虑袭来，看到标题宣布欧洲监管机构将开始要求面临洪水风险的房屋在出售时披露其真实风险时，我可能正坐在马桶上刷Instagram。这在里不会发生。如果它在这里发生了呢？噢天哪。我应该卖掉我的房子吗？平均来说，我每天会有一次这样的时刻。我发短信或打电话的朋友都厌倦了听我抱怨。“如果你卖了，你会去哪里，马里奥？奥兰多？你讨厌奥兰多。”
And there are people I'm willing to stay and suffer for. My mother lives down the street. My grandmother is a few train stops away. I've got a whole oddball clan of Dominican immigrant [SPANISH] and [SPANISH] and cousins scattered across the suburbs. Take my uncle, a lung doctor, for instance. When I had a persistent cough last November and found myself without health insurance, he took free x-rays of my chest and handed me an inhaler.
还有一些人我愿意留下来为他们受苦。我的母亲住在街那头。我的祖母在几个车站之外。我有一大群多米尼加移民亲戚和表兄弟散布在郊区。以我的叔叔为例，他是一名肺科医生。去年11月我患有持续咳嗽，且没有健康保险，他给我拍了免费的胸部X光片，并给了我一个吸入器。
How could I abandon a city full of relatives willing to give such kindness? And so I stay here. I live here. I'm resilient. My family-- they're super resilient. But here's how I really feel about resilience.
我怎么能抛弃一个充满愿意给予这种善良的亲戚的城市呢？所以我留在了这里。我住在这里。我是坚韧的。我的家人——他们超级坚韧。但这就是我关于韧性的真实感受。
I loathe it, because resilience, when it comes to climate change in Florida, basically translates into construction-- raising roads, installing pumps, hardening power lines. In just the last few months, Ron DeSantis, Florida's governor, announced more than half a billion dollars in statewide resilience spending to help cities adapt infrastructure. I wish that was reassuring. But it's not even close to enough money to address the problem.
我厌恶它，因为韧性，当谈到佛罗里达的气候变化时，基本上等同于建筑——抬高道路、安装泵、加固电力线。就在过去的几个月里，佛罗里达州州长罗恩·德桑蒂斯宣布了超过5亿美元的全州韧性支出，以帮助城市适应基础设施。我希望这能让人放心。但离解决问题的资金量还差得远。
And it leaves lots of people behind, especially poor people. They're the ones least likely to be able to afford AC during the coming heat waves. They're the ones that go hungry after a big storm. They're already being kicked off the high ground. If this is resilience, let's not be resilient. Instead, let's acknowledge reality. In 25 years, some neighborhoods could be permanently flooded, and in 40 years, almost 90,000 people could have to move.
而且它抛下了许多人，尤其是穷人。他们是最不可能在即将到来的热浪期间买得起空调的人。他们是那些在大风暴后挨饿的人。他们已经被赶出了高地。如果这就是韧性，那我们还是不要坚韧了。相反，让我们承认现实。25年后，一些社区可能会被永久淹没，40年后，近9万人可能不得不搬迁。
And then there's the big one, the hurricane that is going to rip the heart out of this town. The US Army Corps of Engineers fears it could displace up to a million people if it hits during a high tide. And the big one isn't a matter of if, but when. We're overdue for a direct hit. I don't think anyone here understands how to be resilient enough for that.
还有那个大麻烦，即将把这个城镇的心撕裂的飓风。美国陆军工程兵团担心，如果它在涨潮时袭击，可能会导致多达一百万人流离失所。而大麻烦不是“是否”的问题，而是“何时”的问题。我们早就该遭到直接撞击了。我不认为这里的任何人理解如何为此而变得足够坚韧。
When I was a kid, I was told that resilience basically meant pretending that, despite the hazing and the bullying, I was fine. I wasn't. As an adult, I'm being told that resilience means pretending that if we raise the roads and fix the drains, we'll be fine. We won't. The water is going to keep on rising, no matter how resilient we are.
我小时候，有人告诉我韧性基本上意味着假装，尽管有欺凌和霸凌，我还是很好。我并不好。作为一个成年人，我被告知韧性意味着假装如果我们抬高道路、修复排水管，我们就会没事。我们不会。不管我们有多么坚韧，水位只会不断上涨。
Mario Alejandro Ariza. You can read his climate reporting at floodlightnews.org.
马里奥·亚历杭德罗·阿里扎。你可以在 floodlightnews.org 阅读他的气候报道。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and Sean Cole. The people who put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Rudy Lee, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Michelle Navarro, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starecheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和肖恩·科尔制作。今天节目的制作人员包括 Bim Adewunmi、苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、迈克尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、鲁迪·李、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor's Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Emily McAllister, who alerted us to that fishing report on 101.5 FM in Truckee, also produced that story with us.
我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。艾米丽·麦卡利斯特，她提醒我们关注特拉基 101.5 FM 的那份钓鱼报告，也和我们一起制作了那个故事。
Special thanks today to Justin Briggs, Andrew Ponec, Elana Story, Charles Lester, Phil King, Kevin Woodhouse, Mike O'Neill, Miranda Green, Alex Harris, Emily Holden, Sabrina Imbler, John Morales, and Truckee Tahoe Radio for those Fishing Reports produced by Dondo.
特别感谢贾斯汀·布里格斯、安德鲁·波内克、埃拉娜·斯托里、查尔斯·莱斯特、菲尔·金、凯文·伍德豪斯、迈克·奥尼尔、米兰达·格林、亚历克斯·哈里斯、艾米丽·霍尔登、萨布丽娜·因布勒、约翰·莫拉莱斯，以及提供由 Dondo 制作的钓鱼报告的 Truckee Tahoe 广播电台。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows. There's tons of other stuff there, too. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费地收听我们750多集节目的存档。此外，还有视频。有最喜欢的节目列表。上面还有很多其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心 PRX 分发给各公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, recently he went on a big health kick, dropped a few pounds, and was very dismayed at how, I don't know, baggy the seat of his pants were.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，最近他进行了一次大的健康减肥，瘦了几磅，并对他的裤子后面是多么的松垮感到非常沮丧。
My backyard was gone.
我的后院没了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
（音乐播放）